what's up my fellow Geeks Zaki here with
geek culture and today we've got
something very special to unbox we have
the VivoBook S15 OLED beep Edition man I
have to say this is a really cool
collaboration and I'm excited to see how
Asus and babe have combined their
respective strengths to create a unique
and stylish laptop as you know fashion
brands have been looking at other ways
to engage with their consumers in recent
years for instance Asus has joined
forces with the German techware brand
acronym to release the Rog flow z13 and
not to mention there's also the Rog
zephyrus G14 Alan Walker special edition
and this also shows how fashion brands
are willing to be creative and also
experiment with new ideas so with that
said
let's start unboxing this
right off the bat with its packaging you
can see that it just has a lovely design
I don't think you guys will be actually
throwing the Box away I've got the Asus
VivoBook a bathing ape or big for short
you can see that there's an ape head
over here and of course we have baby
Milo because baby Milo is cute ah okay
if you got two sides to this so look at
that oh it's even nicer when it's
colored the laptop I believe is sure we
got more gizmos so let's take all of
this out let's check out the carrying
case also stylized now look at that yo
super cool you got the little Milo and
Friends very cool very comfortable it's
extra padded you got Zips got some
pouches for your mice hard drives very
cool very very very very interesting
sending this aside we have the laptop to
one it just folds like that a bathing it
right and you get a limited edition
Asus VivoBook a bathing ape Milo baby
model here
boom baby Milo
cute that is very cute okay you've got a
nice little stand here
uh oh no it's not a stand it's a laptop
it's a mini laptop for baby Milo check
that out that's so cute
it's the same VivoBook for baby Milo so
here's him we
and now you got baby Milo
staring a little bit too close to a
laptop but I'll allow it moving on to
the start of the show take a look at
this folks that is so cool it's got a
photo etched if I'm not wrong design
here
very nice oh even the even the touchpad
has the Bape design too let's see what
accessories we have too we've got a Bape
Mouse Asus marshmallow Mouse oh that's
cute
Asus marshmallow
beep Mouse right there of course you've
got your
I believe it's a 90 watt charger let's
check it out
yes 90 watt charging adapter and just oh
if you've got stickers for your keyboard
this is the first time I'm actually
seeing something like this and just a
handful of documents I think there's
more bathing ape stickers as well that's
about it for accessories as well so
let's open this up and see how it goes I
love this very nice orange keycap here
and just check out the enter key over
here with its you know diagonal White
Stripes not too sure whether these are
Hazard lines or Lane markings but it's a
really nice touch and just look at the
touch pad you don't feel the edges at
all
it's so cool let's turn this on it
lights up we've got backlit chocolate
keyboards we've got the Asus
a bathing ape logo here that's that's a
nice touch alright folks it seems like
we have to set this up for a little
while but you can already tell the Asus
VivoBook a building 8 Edition is just
simply stylish it just pops if you know
what I'm saying but if you're the kind
of person who is not looking for
something so flashy a little bit more
stealth but still pack a lot of
performance then you guys gotta check
out the Asus Zenbook 14x OLED if you
look a laptop that has both power and
possibility look no further than the
eight hour battery and
2.8 K 120 hertz OLED portable display
powered by the latest 13 gen Intel Core
I9 CPU and rtex 3050 GPU all packed in a
thin 16.9 mm chassis that only weighs
1.5 kilograms so you can stay focused at
work or play for more information check
out asus.com around the bed you can see
that it has its own custom bathing it
wallpaper which I really really enjoy
speaking of which I really love the
build quality it's not as flimsy you do
get a bit of you know Flex on the
screens here but man the screen itself
is
so vibrant from what Asus is touting
this laptop is made from aluminum and
you can already tell it has a very solid
build moreover this laptop is military
grade standard
810h so it is able to withstand some of
the most toughest conditions that being
said you know don't don't Chuck this
laptop anyhow you like it's a very
beautiful laptop and I don't think baby
Milo would agree with that as well now
obviously the standout feature of this
laptop is the screen it's Pantone
validated it's got Visa display HDR true
black 600. now of course some of you
might be saying you know why is it not
4K and I'm sure that Asus has put in
some thought into you know balancing the
battery life and and 2.8k if you will
you have a 75 watt hour battery on this
and that probably explains why the
resolution is dropped to 2.8 K but for a
2.8 K resolution OLED screen 15.6 inch
laptop this is as good as it gets
everything is still sharp the phones are
still sharp the colors are just
mind-blowing not to mention you guys get
very decent sound quality out of the
speakers they are certified by Harman
Kardon and you also have Dolby Atmos as
part of that as well moving over to
Ports you guys get a thunderbolt 4 port
a USB 3.2 gen 1 Port a USB 2.0 type A a
HDMI 1.4 port and a 3.5 headphone and
microphone combo Jack
so plenty of pots to go around but
having a USB hub is always a good choice
with laptops so however why is this
laptop features up to a 13th gen Intel
Core I9 processor up to 16 gigabytes of
lpddr5 RAM and a whopping fast one
terabyte pcie 4.0 SSD of course
performance also depends on the
configurations that you guys want in
your laptop but what I have here in this
unit is fully specced out I would say
this is more considered as an Ultrabook
than a gaming laptop so that is
something to bear in mind and even so I
have to say that this laptop performs
very well for daily tasks and
productivity heck we even had some
casual gameplay on this with Hades at
2.8k resolution and it's still very
battery smooth and yeah you're still
gonna have a good time but of course
once we get into heavier games like Apex
Legends set to default that's where you
start to see the Riverboat you know
China keep up with the high demand again
overall I'm really impressed with the
VivoBook S15 OLED so with that I would
say this is perfect for beginner level
content creators and students embarking
on their creative Journey that would
like more style so we're gonna wrap
things up here thank you so much for
watching if you like this video be sure
to subscribe to geek culture for more
content just like this and if you have
any questions leave a comment below and
I'll be happy to answer them so the next
one this is Zaki adios
foreign